[Musique]
je suis sabrina ouazani et j'interprète
le rôle de dean est ce tu m'appelles
laetitia et j'interprète le rôle de
sarah l'alpha oui l'alfa notre héroïne
[Musique]
à
québec une question c'était mieux avant
bien sûr c'était mieux avant itunes en
fait c'est m voilà c'était en fait
c'était mieux avant avec diam's mais ça
va être très bien maintenant et après
avec originalité
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
bah ya toujours eu des la vulgarité des
insultes etc mais je trouve qu avant il
y avait quand même on racontait des
histoires quoi un peu plus un peu plus
après nous reste encore un des rappeurs
qui ont qui ont une belle plume et qui
qui écrivent des bonnes choses qui
quittent dénonce des choses qui qui qui
éveil des consciences qui amène au débat
il y en a encore mais j'avais
l'impression que j'ai l'impression qu'il
y en avait plus avant c'était mieux
avant et un changement de forme ouais
ouais c'est un changement de fond en
vrai de vrai pour moi il ya une c'est
notre manière de raconter la vie c'est
notre manière et ils sont plus dans
l'imaginaire ils sont plus dans la
romance met en scène c'était plus pour
dénoncer ce qui se passe maintenant dans
les quartiers extérieurs maintenant
c'est plus on ne raconte plus qu'on a
envie d'avoir plus tard eh oui je
comprends grosse grosse
[Rires]
voilà la vérité c'est maintenant la
arrêté c'est mieux maintenant les clash
mais là franchement par contre c'est le
côté très très voyeuriste qui parle tu
vois on ne disait je me rappelles tu
voir boiron disent aimer c'est
incroyable mais c'est pas ce qui se
passe derrière tu bandes ça s'envoie une
petite punchline on devra attendre que
le son de l'autre sort pour savoir
qu'est ce qui va répondre à la
coqueluche du vote du précédent et s'est
fait jour tu vois ce que je veux
maintenant c'est sur les réseaux sociaux
ont instauré un poste ça va ça va
beaucoup plus vite donc c'est une
manière encore différent de ce clash et
je dirais
[Musique]
l'impression car bondé qui avait déclaré
qu'il y avait des termes un peu spéciaux
que ça parlait de boules qui coûte de
trucs de société tout de suite ça
faisait les grands titres tout de suite
c'était voilà maintenant c'est
l'impression que ça s'est un peu
banalisé et que dans un sens ça donne
plus de liberté
en tout cas moi personnellement tank
rappeuse jeu j'ai plus de liberté à dire
ce que j'en vienne et l'exprimé comme je
le ressens avec la vulgarité ou non je
veux la violence ou non que je veux la
douceur aussi
quand j'ai commencé le rap je faisais
beaucoup de fun bike beaucoup de
concerts et c'est vrai que souvent quand
ou rap c'est pour donner ses protégés à
entendre qu'on voit là et puis aussi ce
délire d'être plein et d'essayer
d'arracher le mic pour donner une petite
partie de ce soir baala maintenant on le
faire la maison
enfin voila c'est galère mais bon c'est
pas grave tant qu'on peut créer on
s'arrête pas à la